thank you
what's going on buddy what a long face
I'm just sick of this black uh
that's all I drink man this is just so
boring don't you know about how some
macadamias macadamia nut milk
no man oh it's a coffee creamer dude oh
you just have it behind your back oh my
God it's like you're ready to try this
it's gonna freeze you don't put your nut
in my coffee put that in there Stir It
Up and taste that oh yeah yeah go ahead
man if I use this oil yeah
it's like you have this all set up right
again you know I get bored in my [__]
you've got a little taste I think you're
going to be kind of you're kind of
excited because you know me and my
coffee dude I know I don't you don't
like to mess around but go ahead and
tell me what you think now huh oh my God
I told you
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
welcome to the no cuss zone no cussing
if you guys are tuning in for cussing
then you better turn the channel it's
not what we do no we are Crystal Clean
on this platform we got that new new
though look at the new studio look yeah
guys I took a little trip to Colombia
and as usual I let Brennan do all the
worrying and all the detailed stuff
thank you chin as well did pay for the
chairs though the counts for something
right I buy you fly you know what I'm
saying yeah I get it you know what I'm
saying but I like the depth because the
one thing you kept talking about Ad
nauseam when we did when we used the
drinking Bros the depth uh podcast
Studio you were like the depth we just
need to mix it up and you were like it
drives me nuts I need depth we just need
to mix it up get rid of the circus look
there a little bit I like this set to
mix it up and then for the it's gonna be
easier for the guests now instead of the
third chair yeah we'll just see if
you're talking next like owls right here
we are with like a couple of old school
games we booked some big guests got a
big guests coming up so I thought you
know it's time to step up our game at
the refresh I mean step up or go back to
our old school put a little more tension
yeah yeah now now can I just address a
couple things
sure I don't know if you saw the bow
nickel and and Anthony cassar Anthony
cassar is uh was a heavyweight he was an
NCAA Champion I know and the nickel and
you do so the nickel and Anthony came
here when we did food truck he's a giant
heavyweight dud badass he's a badass and
he's doing MMA now yeah now now and then
Bo nickel I don't know if you know this
he can fight a little bit of a decorated
wrestler I watched a lot of Bo Nichols
wrestling before he was kind of known
so I think Beau actually won the NCAA as
a freshman I think I'm right about that
anyone uh he won the Heisman of
wrestling as well in college insane yes
so I'm gonna fight the both of them and
um yeah what's more of a waste of time
you fighting both of them which don't
want to watch or are you going to
Colombia the other day that's a very
good question right we're gonna get into
I call you Brian I waste my time Cal
we'll get into Colombia in a little bit
we'll get it it's going to be in a
little bit um but with Bo nickel says
Anthony so they said so Beau said if if
I can last uh just 10 seconds now Bo
here's what you think
and not tap you out yeah no no but both
of them on against me now here's the
thing Bo I I do have an idea of what
it's like to be grabbed by a guy like
you because I've I've had Anthony uh
Daniel Cormier double leg me and he
tapped Me by just putting his chest into
my my his shoulder into my chest sure
and he was giggling and then Luke
rockhold grabbed the whole man and gave
me a little crab ride and sure stuff
some tough guys now I've had Brendan
Schaub yep a bit of a gorilla himself
yep grab onto me know a couple things
about wrestling my technique's probably
not as good as bows but stronger you
know this bow right well now you're yeah
yeah you're bam bam yeah Bam Bam right
but when it comes to wrestling he Bam
Bam no no he'll throw me around yeah
yeah so I'm very aware that I don't
actually I actually don't think I would
last 10 seconds not a chance it's one of
them no not a chance it'd be such a
problem because now now take a look at
that champ now the only discussion Bo is
I know you guys are talking about a
young chimp I was actually talking about
that's a full-grown male a mature male
no no it's losses it's it's for and it
is about a 200 pound animal I've talked
to a primatologist about that I showed a
primatologist that picture yeah but I
think Bo's talking about like your
run-of-the-mill like chimp that Michael
Jackson like an 80 pound champion like a
chimp Michael Jackson yeah an adolescent
chimp
they didn't address unfortunately both
of them we're not talking about this
though yeah now that is not hearing a
peep out of both of them no even on that
map
it's jacked and it's also it's got a
primal it's got a primal strength please
understand there are a couple things I
know Bo's not afraid of strength now now
chin if you could look up
um what a female 80 pound gorilla pulled
in the Bronx Zoo it pulled with one arm
some ungodly amount of weight an 80
pound check with their T yeah that's
that chip looks like he's mad that's 200
pounds looks like if you step on his
lawn he's gonna use the end well the
primatologist told me that that chimp
would pull your head off it would pull
your head off and you need to talk to a
doctor to confirm this right this is the
audience right but more importantly more
importantly
um what we didn't take into account is
that thing is going to bite you oh it's
got a bite force that's that I remember
a gorilla now I don't know if you know
this but a 400 500 pound gorilla has a
bite force a 1300 PSI that's a lot
please hold a tiger has a bite force a
bear grizzly bear has a bite force of
under a thousand about 950 yeah they buy
it hard uh and a tiger has one about a
little over a thousand this boat talking
about biting and anything goes because
that that chimp has got a very strong
bite force which is going to take your
it's going to take your digits and well
how big was the chimp that the lady was
hooking up with and he was like you know
what that was a 200 pounds I'm gonna rip
your face off it's 200 pound champ he's
bowing that and homeboy Anthony beating
up a 200 pounds also and Anthony love
you guys and and huge fans but um please
understand also the chimp that took that
woman's face off was shot it was stabbed
and then it was shot by the police I
think about six times and got took all
Six Bullets and climbed up on top of the
roof yeah and then eventually died so
technology has come a long way though
yeah but back then she was on like Maury
Povich and it's just it's like 90s her
face was a mess yeah yeah so so
um that I guess we were we had our we're
both talking about like a like the
Michael Jackson chimp like that's it
that's a baby that's so anytime she
chimp with a white face it's a baby
well see I think Bo's talking about
chimp and white face and not blackface
he Beau had a little experience I think
with the chimp that's not an adolescent
champ or a younger chimp and and but now
Beau even said that the two of them
together could take a chimp like that uh
200 pounds no and he's yeah it's just
not happening no guys it's not happening
though now there's only one way to find
out though get that black Face Chimp no
no I wouldn't allow them to do it
because I don't want them to get hurt I
don't want their I don't want digits
coming off I don't think anyone's gonna
allow them to do it
now
if we muzzled the chimp
if we muzzle this there's no biting yeah
it'd be very interesting because then
maybe again I'm with Bo on this if it's
a small adolescent chimp yeah him and
his boy are going to stomp that thing
yeah they're gonna get out get behind it
right yeah but I'm talking about a 200
pound chimp with a muzzle on it 200
pounds 200 pounds are both screwed you
think so I think them and Us in here
would be screwed I don't think well six
guys could if you look at what they're
saying I don't know there's a there's a
thing about the Bronx Zoo where the
female 80 pound chimp pulled some crazy
amount of weight over a thousand pounds
with one hand something crazy weird
strength they say that a chimp I don't
know how they measured this but they had
a chimp that deadlifted 1700 pounds
which is insane
so I'm not sure about the Bronx Zoo go
to that one says go up which says how
strong is a chimp really yeah now again
is this white face or black face chimps
big difference
yeah it says chimpanzees are five to
eight times stronger than people yeah
now that's a lot
um
yeah I don't know they the gorillas are
crazy the 500 pound gorilla they were
talking about was just nuts but I don't
know but I feel like this is all common
sense she shows to watch this watch this
then amazingly one of the Bronx gimzees
a former circus ape named Suzette
managed to pull
1200 pounds yeah but the mountain can do
that uh no the mountain can't pull 1200
pounds above I don't think 1200 like
this like pulled it wrote it like
apparently it was sitting it was on
Wheels hold it for mangoes no no not on
weeks I think it was a weight
so it's not it says another one pulled
847 pounds of one hand now now that's
insane now what does that mean like a
good point that if it's on Wheels it's a
whole different thing I'm talking about
did it pull
um
yeah so that's 500 pounds now so he this
is an actual weight
yeah
yeah there's a diameter is he a diameter
damn meter yeah it's an apparatus it's
an apparatus that would give you a list
huh Daddy
all right you know what I'm saying the
point is think about how strong that is
think about how weird I don't think
anybody's like what chimps are strong we
all know this right I'd love to see them
fight it's never happening though no
there's no way to prove it without them
losing eyes and arms and legs how would
I the only way I made a video about it
the only way I'm going to survive Bo and
Anthony in in that situation is if I'm
completely naked yeah I give up your ass
I gotta get my ass and then they're
going to be like it's like Kryptonite
because I'm gonna I'm gonna be turning
my butt to them every time there's
literally nothing you can do that's all
you got to do right there's nothing they
can do against the chimp there's nothing
you do against them no not nothing just
two large men you'd be screwed right
yeah yeah but especially trained guys
I'm just saying dude straight up large
Bros
yeah like two strong Bros it'd be a
problem
you're doing whatever they want huh
you're doing whatever they want right
I'm I'm pretty Fierce dude I'm actually
fierce
I'll tell you what was hot Phoenix
you don't have the record for over it's
like over 115 for 40 days in a row so
insane 115 degrees
what are you talking here's a step for
your ass you know when you see those
those cactuses like the the main
cactuses you know the green with the
main catch you always see yeah you know
when you see a giant one like a 40-foot
one you know they're like 450 years old
they've been there for over four they
grow an inch a year so when you see a
40-foot like those huge cactuses they've
been there for hundreds of years really
I didn't know that either had to look it
up wow the more you know yeah and people
come in there and chop them down you're
like I think it's illegal it is illegal
isn't that crazy yeah when you see those
giant ones they've been there hundreds
of years that's crazy I know then all I
was doing was looking at Cactus the
whole time
oh
I told you my koi came back I thought
they were all killed oh did they come
back hibernating yeah I'm obsessed with
my fish too you lied you know you lied a
little bit you told me look at that what
125 years old
average lifespan 150 they weighs six
tons or more as tall as 50 feet
wow so it's actually not 400 years old
but it is 175 years old
some live over 200 years
some are even older than that if you go
up to a long time I mean that's foreign
it says anything over 40 foot tall is
well over 200 years old wow
that's a cactus has seen some
[__]
that red was what a thousand years old
wasn't that I mean you know
I just didn't know cactuses I mean think
if you had a cactus farm you bet you're
just doing it for you what's going on
future generation thinking about it the
cactus farm yeah no it takes forever
if you want one it's like for my kids
kids kids yeah
that's a beautiful Cactus though look at
that old granddaddy was about 300 years
old that's a big boy
isn't that crazy yeah Phoenix is um
I like it I was uh I went hiking out
there
and then that really went out and I got
a little spooked I told you because
Steven said that they had seen Jaguar
tracks in Arizona came all the way up
and I was like well weird to get killed
by a Jaguar a Jaguar out there it's hot
man hot God damn it's hot
um I took chin to JT wings
hey we almost hit an armadillo and
Austin remember
we did you mean it yeah
you don't remember oh when we were
driving at night yeah a little armor in
the Mexico Place yeah good luck good
luck to your car those baby tanks how
good was that that Mexican authentic
that Mexican food it was so good it's
awesome
but I took chin to JT Wings chin helped
those wings lived up to the hype they
were absolutely delicious yeah here's
the problem our friend chin has a
drinking problem
every time it's him you're not drinking
I'm like no dude here we go we used to
drink together all the time but now you
stopped out of alcoholic anymore
in your liver I know I told you stay in
the same chair I cut back so much when I
had a vacation or you know vacation yeah
but we're at the fights I turn around
like did you drink in white clothes like
it's all they have it doesn't mean you
have to drink what's your drink of
choice just beer I like beer now just
beer before when I was drinking a lot
when your liver was gone
yeah it was wine really I thought
because it's like less calories less
sugar only here
at home you'd go and drink wine wine
yeah how many bottles it would be like
literally a bottle of wine a day that's
it that's it I mean every single day
seven balls of wine a week yeah it's
every it was everything 28 in a month or
drinking here too sometimes I would
drink drinking whiskey all day long
pretty much pretty much man yeah yeah it
was not good
drunk an entire time doing that drunk
have you ever seen me like well we got
Kratom going what's up we got Kratom
going I saw you drunk at the Jelly Roll
concert that was oh yeah you were white
girl wasted 100 really because I did we
too I don't know I don't do weed so wait
so we usually you have running through
your system you would have you have
caffeine
to me that's the most safest thing I've
taken so sure
it's naturally it bottles of wine a
month yeah the wine is got the wine
bottles wise a lot yeah that's why
you're like only a bottle a day that's a
lot dude
that's amazing I already thought about
28 yeah but yeah and then and then you
have uh
because sometimes you have more than a
bottle yeah sometimes yeah sometimes
let's round it up to 35 bottles but then
also in the ingredients also in the
green room we sell tiger three I told
Jamil you sold out because yeah but they
drank two bottles in the Green Room like
you're doing two bottles like chin was
thirsty pretty thirsty we're probably
adding five or six bottles of whiskey a
month not anymore not anymore though
about it but he likes to party yeah I
like to enjoy it and your liver is got a
thick layer of fat all around it let's
go that's going down Maddie after this
weekend didn't help no can we take a
little break dude because we we do have
the Covina day it's only the eighth now
two shows on the eighth those are almost
sold out of fact it's you and me
together for the first time in a hot
second that's right it's mean Big Gulp
Berry Covina September 8th Friday night
because Saturday night on the on
September 9th we're in Austin back with
our friend Joseph Rogan you me and who
else and Sam tripley because Eddie
Bravo's gonna be in Japan so we called
up our next friend who does conspiracies
his name Sam
and he goes um I'm thinking of suing but
I can't afford Morgan and Morgan Morgan
and Morgan you follow your friend got an
accident you can file a claim for your
cash Morgan Warren's the biggest injury
law firm in the country and by the way
filing a claim is about as easy as
ordering takeout okay are you kidding me
dude no I'm not and they've recovered
billions of dollars are you saying if
I'm ever injured I need to check out
Morgan and Morgan heavy on the Morgan
look it's more like using an app than
hiring a lawyer can I give you some
stats 35 of all fatal accidents okay
occur between 6 p.m and midnight people
is 25 to 34 had the highest amount of
drivers involved in car crashes people
age 15 to 24 at the highest rate of
emergency room visits due to car
accidents of all age groups now you get
hurt you have to miss work there's a lot
of things you're not suing the person
you're usually suing the insurance
company yeah don't feel bad it's a
minute claim free yeah dude some minutes
claim to Morgan and Morgan is the
easiest swiping right on a dating app
and you're failing at that so don't fail
when you get in a car crash why'd you
say they were failing at that that's
mean well you know what's tough out
there on the streets it really is it
really is that easy if you're ever
injured you can check out Morgan Morgan
their fee is free unless they win for
more information go to
forthepeople.com fighter that's
forthepeople.com fighter or dial pound
law pound five two nine from your cell
phone that's for the people.com fighter
pound law pound 529 from your cell phone
this is a paid advertisement Morgan and
Morgan Henry sahuto came to show us all
old Triple C it's pretty cool it's all
true I saw all my old friends yeah Ed
Herman Joy Bill Sonora CB dollaway Corey
sanna Hagen wow bunch of people it's
really cool they all came out yep oh I
met uh
uh what's the magician's name Chris
Angel Chris Angel did you really oh
what's he like he's cool he loves MMA
knows his stuff loves them in me you
don't always like I mix oh I know a lot
about how much he makes I didn't I know
because residency does 500 shows a year
70 million a year yeah I know what his
contract was 70 mil yeah
yeah oh yeah
he's he's a Good Time Charlie he goes oh
I'm starting but podcast I've had Mike
Tyson on this guy this guy I'm like oh
cool why
yeah if you make 70 million a year why
are we talking a podcast I know just be
just bored you know what else does magic
yeah hey B you know what else does magic
when he's single to pick up the ladies
Chandler magic just to pick up hoes what
I learned it from the game remember the
book The Game uh-huh that guy I read
that book the main guy mystery yeah uh
Neil Strauss I don't like that book but
I've read it I told chin I said if you
have to do magic pick up Blaze might not
be for you that was when I was younger
and it worked I told Brandon actually
worked yeah strangely drawn not in 2023
a quarter tiny girls there like what is
is that a rabbit in your purse like Beat
It creep yep yeah I don't think you do
in 2023 back like early 20 early 2000s
probably popping yeah this day and age
dude that's assault Brother I can't be
doing that that's very interesting I
cringe when I think about it too but it
worked listen it does work yeah it
worked it's so crazy there's a rabbit I
told you my ex-wife who was gorgeous Max
wife goes I had no idea Chim was so
handsome well thank you I'm like hey man
what's going on here yo and well let her
know he knows magic yeah
my ex my ex had a probably had a taste
of the old Asian fever oh really I think
she dated a photographer who was uh
there's a reason she wanted to do date
night at PF Chang's all day heavy on the
Chain that's right that's right you like
the orange chicken here is all right my
wife said I said she went on a date in
Japan with an MMA fighter who was a
giant Russian guy
and she goes and but your ex or your
current no my accent she goes but you
know but Amanda was always like she was
like I said so what happens because
nothing that guy was too big and too
scary I was like no thanks she's just
not that's a lot hey
hey oh you think the Russian MMA fighter
took no for an answer
sir I just know her oh you don't think
she no no she's way more down by the
Russian hey we can't do that we can't
actually get mad
you're so weak dude I like Howard Stern
now I don't know we used to be wild man
no now we had a Sons to stop cussing
can't say bite down why not pipe the
Russian Piper dude the Russian Pipeline
that's very funny the Russian Pipeline
dude he's more into like like I think
she'd be more into an older gangster
type so if he's an older gangster ran
everything older gangster rush it yeah
but not a young yeah young muscular kind
of guy I don't look the same age out
there no not the same hey Russian
Pipeline yep don't say Russian Pipeline
Russian Pipeline I'm gonna have some
magic mind right now you need it dude
yeah hopefully that takes your sensors
off I ran out of it so I got to get more
I travel with it now I know I brought it
two why did you brought it to Phoenix
are you drinking how many are you doing
a day uh two drink one two to three you
are yeah they sent me a whole package of
the crib they know what I do Daddy I do
want to tell you if you want me to work
with it you know I got problems yeah
yeah I knew I knew you'd take a lot but
they say it's like a Five Hour Energy
Shot so don't but way better than that I
know clean and good but even Jay was
like man you he was like let's get
coffee I'm like I'm good once you'd
start doing it she's like what happened
to you yeah everybody I would say this
everyone who takes it
um misses it when they don't everyone
who takes it designs their own app like
my wife's like where's the where's the
freaking magic mine I'm like we ran out
she's like we'll get more
you might hate chicken did you say relax
you become like a fanatic that's what
you do it could be good for you magic
mind you should try it dude yeah
remember cats after dark we did all the
time oh well I wasn't on that show well
I mean neither is Brian so we don't know
man all right
it was on your channel thick boy chin do
you have any magic up your sleeve right
now I wish if we had cigarettes I could
I could do something
cigarette yeah who are you and by the
way like my nephew coming does this
stuff really work yes it really works I
wouldn't be talking about it if it
didn't really work it's awesome and it's
tasty every day
I'm not taking something you know from
my I'm taking it from my health no I
don't take any Adderall I take one cup
of coffee a day did you have any
withdrawals from the adderall addiction
no man I'm not a [__]
I absolutely I did I said my brain was
so messed up oh dude
disaster I can't believe I got through
that yeah
speaking of Russian Pipeline it was hard
huh yeah the hardest really yeah cold
turkey
sweat that night foggy brain during the
day yep well guess what weiners still
worked though daddy decided to eat a
bunch of Thai food very spicy Thai food
right before I went to bed big old piece
thing of sticky rice Columbia no no no I
was in oh I got I got a story on that I
decided to take uh sticky rice and then
all that spiced chicken and I woke up at
2 30 in the morning wide awake and I
cleaned through your brains out oh Bloom
I took 17 sometimes that's fun though
right yes but I cleaned Windows it was
like I was a meth addict my neighbors
that they could see inside my house
would be like that guy's a meth addict I
was cleaning why the windows because I
just couldn't sleep and I was like oh
these windows I was like I need to clean
them Oh I thought you were saying you
like clean like the the bathroom with
your dookie oh I did that too came back
uh from Colombia I don't know yeah I
think so let's go back to it so uh
there's a remote control but comfortable
it's Brian hasn't installed it yet I
told him not to worry about it for now
since it's our first show yeah I mean
came back from Colombia came back from
Colombia
um uh with the worst food poisoning
what'd you eat I think I ate some
Colombian ass chicken
in a sandwich at the airport
yeah bro no you can't even I was like
this chicken says funny I'll just power
through and oh boy oh boy like the kind
of hurt attacks your whole body yeah
your skin 24 hours oh yeah 24 hours like
my skin I was like oh I could barely
move it'll make you lose some weight
though that's what I appreciate um in 24
hours 24 hours didn't need anything for
really 48 I was like it's like you're
cutting weight just a different way yeah
that's bad that's like when I see people
at laxing that sushi I'm like what are
you doing airport Sushi oh no forget it
Colombia by the way more plastic surgery
I've never seen more fake butts fake
boobs and fake lips love it but add to
the fact
in fact they're all so beautiful
beautiful to begin with like I don't
like some guy said he was a guy kind of
recognizing me there and he goes I said
the women like if if you're a young man
there it's a disaster yeah move this he
goes
it's like they took for 300 years they
took any woman that was not perfect and
threw her off a cliff yeah and like just
purified force them to move yeah and
then just the most beautiful women in
the world I mean literally you're just
like what is going on here is it true
there's more like hotties than there are
dudes out there like there's more
females yeah the women are much better
looking than the men but there's do you
see some ugly tourism it's actually like
Thailand so that part of it is part of
the economy is there's a lot of sex
tourism there man in fact when you go to
certain places that we go to it says we
don't serve sections oh that's terrible
we gotta put a stop if you're a young
person yeah and you're and you're and
you're you're trying to walk a straight
line don't go to Columbia I'm gonna go
down and do some research and put an end
to this
I'm I need to do some Fields probably go
do some field research okay I have no
reason to go down bring your lady
because bring your lady sure
although you know what your lady is yeah
those women have nothing on you late no
I mean you know yeah and her stuff's
real yes I don't hate on the fake stuff
either though man no you don't no you
don't you do though you seem
condescending well you just see this
this overwhelming like room when you're
like oh boy that's you know you didn't
need to do that yeah
what's wrong with you dude who are you
I can't say Russian Pipeline you're not
into big asses anymore dude I'm just
scared I'd like to be a little natural
that's all you like Howard Stern man one
of our friends that go are they real
because if you can touch them they're
real too don't ask dumb questions 100 I
just
yeah I know but they're real real nice I
like technology real nice to look at
especially this day and age what they
can do with asses yeah well nowadays
they put the actual your own fat into
your breasts and your butt yeah BBL yeah
they've still never figured out the face
well they have nah Simon Cowell
yeah he's done some stuff to his face
yeah he put all the Botox in his face oh
it's terrible he had to come out and
address he's like I made some mistakes
but he did yeah I think I might have
made that part up okay no I think he did
come out and say he made some mistakes
yeah I I just think I I don't know what
he's doing
I don't know what he's he looks like a
wax figure on the right there dude
that's fake that has to be fake
he's addressed to bring if you go to
type in his name and then just hit the
recent news don't do before and after
and just say do they have news option on
this yeah yeah filler and all that stop
it right now some Cal Sports fresh
concern over his face
some cows terribly criticized for his
physical change yeah just be
just have
be an older guy
well he does look different here what if
I show up like this are you gonna freak
out if I'm like hey guys I would love
that what's going on guys really good to
see you
uh no you know what I just I'm just
young and I just been eating well
he looks like he's fighting g-forces all
the time
all right well go up go fight g-forces
bro
oh that's someone else to put the botox
is wearing off Simon yeah I know some
people that poor guy like that he's just
fighting father time and he's down on
the cars 10-8 I know people who are um
well don't wear that jacket either
please also button it up more yeah yeah
it's like a samurai yeah I know people
that tend to um
I know some actors who do that stuff I
look at their face and I'm like what's
going on with your face bro how come
it's not moving we all know what's going
on I know you've never done that well
you did it once right no Botox I don't
know the [__] would I do it before
now if anything I need I don't need to
add more to my face take away filler in
your lips I wish dude I wish I if I
could I wish they could just I had
somebody tell me that they like they're
like running this gets his lips done and
I was like what [__] you know he gets
his lips done got these from my Daddy
doesn't get his lips done where would
you get it you got your eyebrows and
your lips done I go no it doesn't that's
a compliment I know yeah I was like it
doesn't get his lips done he's just I'll
have a straggler my girl will take it
off every now and then but now I woke up
like this [__]
dim the rules dim the rules are you
looking forward to the fights this
weekend
um you have no idea what's this weekend
can I see who's fighting UFC 292
pay-per-view Boston oh my God
no don't act like you're excited for it
you had no clue no I don't act like
you're following the sport but let's
fake it no I am I'm gonna entertain me
now
um no I'm super excited Ian Machado Gary
Neil magni is great Cheeto
oh so Chris Weidman and Brad Tavares are
not on the main card since it's updated
yeah since they lost you know I'm
rooting for Cheeto we all are buddy I
think they'll still move that fight up
because they have to put five on the
main card so you assume they move up
Chris Weidman who else wouldn't
they should move over Chris Weidman and
move up Andre petrovski
Gerald Mercer to the prelims
yeah it's a great fight so first first
fight for Chris in a long time Chris why
don't we ask since he broke his leg Yeah
against Brad Tavares he's uh he's a
pretty big dog lost 200 or something
almost almost 300. yeah
um how old is Chris now
uh 74 in five years Austin Hubbard and
Kurt are fighting this the alternate uh
Fighter finale he's 39 by the way wow
Chris is yeah wow I think he's his last
one Win Lose or Draw I think he's
talking about he'll spend more times
with his kids yeah
and then the ultimate fight I know you
haven't watched that but it's been tough
watch that should be completely honest
it's been a tough follow I know Austin
Hubbard and Kurt are the it's the finale
that's how you know the show's doing dog
crap because they they used to be their
own Fight Night Main Event like when I
thought Roy we're the main event can I
get your main cards give me your picks
dude
I'm going Sean O'Malley
I think Sean's got that feeling bad well
I know I know what you're thinking I
know exactly what you're thinking
um I know and uh you're thinking that
there's no way that Sean solves that
algeman Sterling wrestling it's not a
knockdown Suga there's nobody in the
division who can like he did he took
down sahudo I know how he does against
murab like it's crazy
like he's just time it's just his time
but everyone goes everyone goes it's a
bad matchup for sugar shot that's not a
knock-on show he's a bad match for
everybody there's nobody in the top ten
that he's not a nightmare for with his
skill set Sean's too strong
um X Factor he just he's truly Rises to
every occasion and surprises everyone
the fan base disagree we all love Suga
here yeah so did he rise to the occasion
against Pedro Munoz did he rise to the
occasion against Cheeto Vera
so that doesn't work so when you say
rise to the occasion what do you mean
and now he now here to defend you he did
do against Peter Yan that was his best
performance I've ever seen and I
actually thought he was going to win
that fight that's what I mean and that's
what I was so important that's the one
time but he's look at his win streak
like Marlon he lost boy didn't he didn't
he get his foot broke right his foot he
hit that nerve he couldn't stand up he
was losing that fight yeah but no he
lost it but but no there's no but he
lost that fight so so with with with
um
Pedro was an i i gouge yeah with with
algerman I guess the idea would be let
me just come I'm his coach can I give
you my my game plan if you're as coach
I'm for sure been against them let me
just be let me be a coach yeah you got
him you got him standing you keep a
distance now algeman is no slouches yep
you you you box him you punch him you
kick him when he gets taken down the
only thing you want to do is stand up
you keep standing up you keep standing
up you keep standing up and that's what
I'm saying that's so stupid no but I
don't but
uh okay let me show you sugar said that
Sugar said this on uh he he sat down in
a good interview with Brad akamoto I
just didn't like where his head out with
this because he goes you know obviously
Al Joe's really good Grappler so strong
his takedown if you get your back it's a
nightmare he goes I just gotta survive
down there I was like I hate when guys
say survive I'm like oh so you're you're
already giving in that you're gonna get
taken down
if your plan to survive and not you know
get back to your feet or not put up a
fight there's no way you're surviving
yeah I would say I would say though it's
a given in your game plan that you're
probably going to get taken down right
there's not much you can do you can't
say survive though yeah
that he might mean don't let him take
your back and wear you down that way
right so no he said survive well does
that mean play that means keep them in
your guard good luck on your guard yeah
hard to do I think algae is almost a 400
favorite which is Big rightfully so
because if you're a sugar fan you gotta
hope that he can catch him before he
gets taken down on the feet for five
rounds
you're betting on that which it's tough
to do aljo doesn't get caught very much
Marlon Mirage did it to him but outside
that happened in 2017. so you're saying
uh
not sure I don't have I'm sorry I I
think
the fan base and you'll see want sugar
to win but but there's only so much you
just don't see all right so I'm close
with I love both these guys I hate this
is take take my but you're just nice out
of it you're just being a strict analyst
no emotion correct you don't you don't
it's fair to say you don't see how sugar
solves the wrestling of algerman nobody
that's not knock on sugar nobody can I
know even look at Henry that's insane
right no I talked I talked to anybody's
again when you're against the wall like
he does some things man it's tough to
deal with he's like everyone goes he's
so strong is he so strong weird strong
he's gonna go up to 45 this place last
fight at 35 he's gonna go up to 45 he's
big it's just his time it's a tough
fight for sugar but what you're betting
on is sugar catches him now sugar is
striking wise has a huge Advantage yeah
he's creative he's good with both legs
both he can he can go Orthodox South
Paul like he's such a Savage an athlete
and I I would say very athletic not more
athletic than Al Joe yeah that's a good
question well I think close I don't
think uh I don't I I as far as like
explosiveness and no I mean way better
than people you got to come credit for
being a very good athlete not now he's a
good athlete but Alex was a hell of an
athlete what was alzo's wrestling
pedigree stud yeah stud yeah College
wrestler but Al Joseph Phenom man that
kid's a complete freak yep probably the
best banana way to ever do it really
you make a good point
he's also huge he beats Edinboro
in 2017. does he get down to that weight
this is his last fight at 35 though I
think
yeah he's gonna let marab now now I
think Murad versus I think once aljo
leaves it suga's division
I mean sure you can beat morab I think
sure you can do well against Corey
sandhagen you think he beats morav I do
doesn't he have the same problem with
Murad no because marab's not as
talented when it comes to the Jiu Jitsu
um
okay and Henry sahuda can mix it well
together marab's still not there yet
Rob's tenacity and takedowns are similar
against the case emotionally I'm going
with sugar yeah I love sugar so because
I just think yeah if sugar one I'd be
stoked what would you tell him how do
you deal with that wrestling would you
say nothing do you have to keep standing
up
yeah you got to get up you gotta get off
the fights in in the in the transitions
yes like don't don't just uh don't just
don't survive your takedown defense got
to be everything
you think you're taken down
but you got to make him work and then
hope he hopefully he gets tired in the
third again in that camp with all those
you know those those ASU wrestlers you
know and and and where CB Dalloway
trains all those guys you're in there
with those wrestlers they're taking you
down taking you down all your practicing
is take down defense that's all you're
doing right that's a huge part of your
Camp no because you got to do what you
do yeah I'm sure you'll do what you do
you know like there's always something
you're not gonna go Toe to Toe with them
and try to not get taken down you're
just not you gotta hope that eventually
you can't use and show you're so
talented stand up like you can
definitely catch him yes he can
definitely win he's not a Bad Bet yeah
start boxing his ears out if he's there
to get hit the other thing is aljo's not
like a knockout artist so she can take
some chances on the feet too because you
need to take him down might as well go
balls to the wall so there's that too
and sugar hits you you're going out yep
sure all that stuff that being said he
went bet on it huh you want Bet On It
again it's not a Bad Bet at all you want
to bet a thousand dollars sure
how about I don't owe you if it goes to
the decision because it's not fair Mike
is up almost a minus 400. so if alja
wins by decision then it's just we don't
owe each other money
that's good that's very good Oh I
thought you're gonna come with something
else dude okay that's very good
um it's in Boston
yeah very aggressive part of the world
you and I know that
very aggressive you get to fight in
Boston so easily the rest of the card's
quality too
uh next fight
yeah
that's a fun one way they should get
that done shouldn't get punched in the
face imacado Gary I know you're not huge
on him yet you should be he's the next
coming to Conor McGregor is he he has a
different flavor but as far as
confidence like a guy that says
something that comes to fruition he's
very similar bring him up and the dude
has a skill set daddy Neil magni the old
the veteran now Neil's stepping in uh
for a late replacement
yep Neil's got that crazy cardio he's so
tall it's a perfect lot to deal with
it's a perfect fight for young Gary
because why because uh
because uh our boy Neil magni he'll stay
on the outside and play that game and
you know you're gonna be able to see the
skill set of me and Gary striking Wise
High level high level really Savage can
I see you in Gary please tall oh you
want to see his picture how tall would
we say he's tall for the division okay
but he's uh oh I know this guy I know
that kid yeah yeah oh yeah oh he's he's
uh he's got no problem striking I'll
tell you that he's a striker first he's
six three yeah that's a lot to deal with
and you know when guys that are like
arrogant you're like oh God this is lame
when he it's similar to Conor when he
says something like I can't believe it
England he's from Ireland yeah why is
his last middle name Machado he married
a Brazilian yeah he made a Brazilian
yeah okay and he took her name he took
her yesterday his name's Ian Gary and
Gary yeah okay there couldn't be more
Irish dude boxer and the whole thing
he's a Savage yeah
uh that's gonna be a tough one for Neil
tough one for our boy yeah
that kid's the real deal
yeah
it's I love these prospects though when
these guys are coming up to me it's the
best part of the UFC uh-huh see what
they can do
him bow nickel like those I watch out
for Neil Magnus guard
watch out first ground game got them
long legs okay
wow man I'm getting nothing from you huh
no no no his ground's awful Neil yeah
Brandon says so like his is Kryptonite
yeah
no you submitted but he's got long legs
and I'm just feeling like he's I don't
think he has any submissions from his
guard
guard is not what they they're probably
gonna say stay in the guard the only
reason I say that is because I know
civilians that are at high altitude Jiu
Jitsu who roll with Neil they're always
like careful of his guard but those are
guys like me so those are guys that work
at Starbucks now Ian Machado Gary yeah a
little different doesn't give a fine so
when my buddy my buddies are brown both
who's my age says his guard is a
nightmare now love everybody right
you're not rolling with them in Pro
you're Pro but I've been there they roll
over they don't no they just maybe if
you did like a seminar with them maybe
three years ago right but he probably
rolled with him a little bit but day to
day gets in there the pros ain't going
with the jokes he gets in there your
buddy had something to call you about
right he's brown belt yeah sure but he
just gets in there and rolls around he's
got a new friend line
not using your Banker friend to roll
with to get ready for Ian Machado Gary
is that right okay
uh maybe if they're in the class or
whatever but yeah all right all right so
you're not your money's on in yeah
unfortunately yeah younger Young Gun the
New Black kid's the real deal got it and
then our boy cheat over his Pedro that's
the best fight in the card as far as
stylistically
action-packed what's your thought on
that I got cheetah all day daddy I think
he gets it done three rounds too she's
been used used to five Pace himself I
think he comes out like a banshee
so she's coming off that controversial
loss to
uh Corey sandagen I saw Corey in uh in
Phoenix he had surgery on his tricep he
said he's out six months let's try said
you completely too much tricep
damn I know
six months because they got a reattached
the bone or something
it's a bad one
it's not good
damn
yeah I guess I'm frustrated you know
that UFC was coming up I want to hit you
I know that's all right I've been in
Columbia bro Colombia yeah doing nothing
right not a lot daddy's been working huh
daddy's been working yeah you can buy um
some of that
for uh I was told you can buy flavored
cocaina very pure for like literally I
think it's five dollars a baggie
eight ball
I don't know that they don't know the
details but I know it's it's about as
expensive I can't believe you're doing
box of tic tacs I think I can't believe
you didn't go on the Pablo Escobar tour
they have a cool tour down there um
apparently there are one of his Mansions
apparently is a also doubles as a
brothel
that I heard that that's this place is
so cool I know I heard that's up in the
hills so you can go there apparently and
it's a high-end brothel oh man um so
they did that to one of us hey take it
easy bro take it easy take it easy
apparently there's that little history I
hated some of the great restaurants
there great food boring you I know I did
old guy stuff yeah I did old guy stuff
but I will say that if you want to get
into that life it's easy you want that
life easy dip your toes you got you you
need only fly about two and a half hours
to three hours from Miami and you're in
it's that close and it's also only two
hours ahead of Los Angeles so you're on
Texas time daddy wow you know Texas time
you understand so you you would you
acclimate right away now I don't know if
you know much about Med dejin but it's 5
000 feet above sea level so you're
training too spring year round yeah oh
wow yeah not tropical kid over there
just move our operation down there
you would have you would have a a good
time we'd have a whole great month run
you can feel the city's heartbeat yeah
yeah the Colombians live from their
hearts and their asses there's a there's
a lot of they're they're a beautiful uh
visceral people they live they are
they're they're they're they their heart
they lead with their heart yeah yeah
okay I like it yeah what do you got chin
so I couldn't quit dreaming about
Colombia you wouldn't want to go to that
Pablo Escobar oh that's up my alley dog
imagine so that you go to these places
it's a very that's a real thing and
Colombia there there are lots of
different because we had I had a driver
there who was like that right that that
that's that's the the strip club that's
the brothel they all the you know it's
all the stuff that you want to get into
you want to if you want any kind of drug
so there's a there's it caters to that
but then it's also got the other stuff
that you can do the boring Sun
great rest restaurants great people sure
great culture yeah whatever yeah what do
you got Jen let's take another break
because listen I know you just found out
about it but UFC 292 is the buzz around
my town right now it's happened in
Boston you got Al Joe fighting sugar
Shawn O'Malley this fight he's going
down this Saturday will the current
champ keep his crown or the sugar Sean
time to shine get your bet on at
draftking Sportsbook the official Sports
button part of the UFC new customers can
bet just five dollar rules to get 150 in
bonus bets instantly dude you also got
um Pedro Munoz Cheeto Vera fighting on
there you got Ian Gary fine our boy uh
the gazelle all right you got Neil magni
fighting you got Chris Weidman come back
from the long injury over Brad Tavares
you got The Ultimate Fighter finale in
Austin Hubbard you got Andre Petroski my
boy out of Philly fighting there's a lot
of ways to make some money with
DraftKings download the drafting
Sportsbook app right now use code
fighter new customers can bet just five
dollars and get UFC 292 to get 150 in
bonus bets instantly that's this
Saturday only at draftking Sportsbook
with the code fighter Cameron probably
called 100 Gamma New York called uh 8778
hope NY on text help NY 467 369 in West
Virginia visit
www.1800 gambler.net in partnership with
Hollywood Casino at Charlestown Races
all games regulated by the West Virginia
Lottery please pay responsibly in
Connecticut is available for problem
gambling at
888-789-777 or visit
ccpg.org on behalf of Boot Hill Casino
and Resorts Kansas 21 and over in most
eligible States but age varies by
jurisdictions even draftkings.com
Sportsbook for details and stay
specifically responsible gambling
resources bonus bets expire seven days
after issuance eligibility and deposit
restrictions apply terms of
sportsbook.draftkings.com MMA terms uh
do you want to start off with this crazy
story of a cannibal yeah so I watched
this documentary yesterday
job some fans into Jay shop he's like
yeah apparently people are saying you
got to watch this oh that guy is awful
he looks like a cannibal so check this
out B this is a crazy story so this guy
was born in Japan goes to study in
France
has always uh wondered what be like to
eat somebody he thinks he's a cannibal
he's working with this young lady in
France decides to shoe in the head so he
can eat her so he invites over to his
apartment they're doing some like
painting or something he just takes a
gun out shoots behind the air kills her
and then he did it because and he always
wanted to know he was obsessed with
thigh so he always wonders what women's
thighs would be like but he decided to
eat her ass first so he he's and they
have these graphic like comic because
they I'll get into what they did with on
the business side but he he started to
try to eat her ass first but said it's
tougher than you think and it was like
hard for him to bite into it because she
had like a muscle like a muscular ass so
then he went and bought a butcher knife
and then ate her thighs uh cut up her
body cut up all of it right and then
puts the body because he was like he's
worried the neighbors like it stinks
because the corpse so he puts his body
into two bags like you know travel bags
he's going down to like some lake or
Pond to dispose them and he's like it
was eight o'clock at night he's like
people are still outside bathing and how
he jumped out of the taxi he's like
everyone's looking so he's like oh got
to do something so he dropped the bag
and just walked off and someone came up
he was like hey man you left this open
it up and all the body parts started
yelling murderer he gets caught four
days later
he gets accused of cannibalism and
murder he gets a you know he gets
trialed and convicted to life in [__]
prison in uh France I think he was
actually put in a it says there's
so they did they actually got uh put
into an Institutional but so they
declared him that he's insane right but
then the French people are like we don't
pay for this random Chinese Killers you
know Japanese Japanese we don't want to
pay for this so they extradite them to
Japan he found a loophole in the system
in Japan because they had him sit down
to psyche people and they're like no
he's fine he's not he's insane but evil
and he just walked scot-free got away
with it so he was living in Japan to the
you know until recently he passed away
recently but Theresa he's a free man
walking around but in Japan they heard
his story they made he made he drew he
made money off books Comics started
doing porno
it's not stupid there's a dark side to
that to that world
and is he dead now chin yeah it died
November 2022 of of what he's four nine
evil he was what four oh my God he's
four nine four nine
yeah whoa he is a just a depraved evil
human being I want to see what it's like
to eat somebody and just killed her oh
but and then so he's always felt like a
cannibal and then he said
always doesn't get his flag but he was
saying that whenever he got the cannibal
urges he would just whack off and it
would make you go away but then he some
reasons his wieners stopped working so
he couldn't whack off so then he started
feeling like a cannibal again
oh my God but at the end of that video
he's like he's like the only thing I
want now is to I just want to die he's
like I have no friends no one associate
with me it's like yeah dude yeah yeah
you killed and ate somebody yeah you ate
people
they show them shooting this porno it's
this attractive Japanese girl she's so
hot I'm like what are you doing so he
they're interviewing before he said yeah
So the plan is I'll have sex with her
first a few times and then we tell her
my history that was the porno so they
get done she has he has a book and has
the someone made a book about it there's
the pictures of the dead body it's so
graphic and she's slipping through and
he's like yeah that was me and she just
starts crying she's like what
it was dark yeah he uh
yeah that might be a picture of that
everything else is like blocked so which
is good
ah
I don't want to see it it's dark dude I
guess it is
it was interesting yeah well there are
some very very dark people in the world
and some real that's one of them who are
into like I don't know if you can up the
ante on that like do you have any
secrets I'm not gonna well okay I'll
tell you but as long as you don't get
mad or like judge me okay and then it's
like okay I kissed somebody and he was
obsessed with women's thighs their
thighs
yeah I'd eat your nose first B
why I don't know it's because I know it
should be chewy it's all cartilage yeah
you try that bad boy it's hard to chew
on me I'm so I'm so dense and muscular
to be honest with you I'm just a rawhide
and cable
turkey yeah bro no you are you know what
you are I got your skirt steak I got
yeah I got chimp meat oh yeah it's a
tough two dollar steak Daddy yeah you're
talking about chimney don't say two
dollars don't say that yeah cheap skirts
today no don't say I'm fine
you want like that rib eye dude look at
that skirt skate yeah that's that's you
that carne asada
carne asada no
you might be you might be tastier yeah
younger marbly a little more fat in
there all marbly yeah you got some dense
I'm like a rib eye dog I don't know you
got Bam Bam muscles you might be
hardness I have to beat that muscle down
oh yeah yeah this big wiener yeah
the pigs under my house no yeah no
that's the best part man I have a hog
frame it I got a hog farming I have a
hog farm and then they poo and I collect
their poo so that nobody there's another
Trace yeah that story is dark though
nonetheless it's very dark yeah yeah how
about Japan was like nah he's fine
and then made money off books comic
books movies yeah this that's a there's
a there's a real dark under tapestry
Market where you can buy in vending
machines
underwear used underwear girls yeah it's
in public dude everyone knows that it's
not that dark I'm talking about there's
a marker there's a real dirty
underground
see they say that in places like Germany
and Japan where manners protocol
discipline and you know cleanliness are
everything
that what happens is when you make
people behave in a very robotic sort of
clean uh uh
Dark World and then it just rears its
ugly head when you know there's there's
the the underground will create vacuums
for the most depraved you grew up that
way and now it's like hey guess what
down here anything goes and they're just
like ah
what else you got you
another not that's dark but not great
one this one here Michael or her this
one's not dark it's it's not cool oh
that's great weights this is a far cry
from the candle definitely not
cannibalism
because the Blind Side was based on a
lie yeah yeah it said that family just
they they never officially adopted them
they just did it to benefit us make
money yeah and he never saw a dime off
the movie and the parents earned all the
money and now he's like hey pay me my
money and also I'm not your son you well
that's hilarious
the 14-page petition filed in the Shelby
County Tennessee alleged that Sean and
the Leah Ann who took uh um or another
home as a high school student never
adopted him instead less than three
months after or turned 18 in 2004 the
paper says the couple tricked him into
sign a document making them his
conservators which gave them legal
authority to make business deals in his
name so they reaped all the benefits of
the movie The merch jeez
he's not so cool so he's he's suing him
for that now he's coming after the money
whoa and he also said the movie made him
seem like he was this dumb black kid
from like this poor neighborhood and
he's actually really smart so it
affected his in the NFL they're like
he's just a big dumb kid oh my God yeah
is he still playing in the NFL no he's
not how long did he play for a while
he's good he must have signed a hell of
a contract though he's got money back
then not too much but I'm sure he has
money did you see that maybe Manziel
Untold documentary great yeah so good
wow that thing will frustrate you wow to
frustrate you because because when
Johnny Manziel uh won the Heisman for
Texas A M they show yeah first freshman
ever they made the just the university
that year made 350 million dollars
Johnny Manziel earned nothing yeah well
that's that's where this NCAA is just
the worst it's so crooked so corrupt he
sold two million maroon Johnny Manziel
jerseys he received nothing so then once
he started they were like hey sign these
autographs pay 30 000 he's like yeah all
right let's do it I don't blame him at
all but but um he I didn't know that he
only played two years at Texas A M yeah
and then he goes to the the NFL how
would he says how would he have done in
the NFL if he was really disciplined was
he you know he's small it's tough he's a
runner and we know what that what
happened well I know he had arm too but
yeah it was just tough it was tough of
that size like those guys really know
could you say he was was he a little bit
like Patrick Holmes though God damn no
well at least I'd rather talk about
fighting but Patrick Holmes runs and
throws no no no he doesn't no no they're
gonna be more opposite but he scrambles
and runs and it's hard to tell he's very
unorthodox no no no no touch my homes it
has a lightning rod Johnny Manziel
didn't have a cannon he didn't have that
he had no accuracy he also had a All-Pro
guy catching for him so he had so he was
they couldn't be more opposite really no
so he came down I mean Patrick Holmes
the best quarterback of all time right
but I mean when I watched them because
I've watched Patrick Mahomes and I've
watched the boat two documentaries they
look like they have a similar oh God no
God no couldn't be further no one's a
one's a gunslinger the other just
improvises makes it work and throws
bombs right but so he's so he wasn't
known for his arm it was more than the
fact that he could run yeah I mean
you're not doing that in the pros right
no any smaller he the better can
comparison would be uh Baker Mayfield
similar size Heisman Trophy winners yeah
no but Patrick homes no so you don't so
you you do you think that he did the
pros would have been a different story
he wouldn't have been Johnny Football on
the pros no not a chance not a chance no
chance do you think he'd be more like
Baker Mayfield do you know do you think
he knew that inherently no I think he
had so much confidence in himself he
thought he was going to be Johnny
Football in the NFL right and he did
pretty well right no this is awful one
of the worst girls of all time
ah
you didn't even watch the dog I did
watch the doctor and then and then how
much film did you watch he goes zero
yeah
you can't do that in the pros he missed
that he thought he could go to Vegas on
a Saturday and make it to the game on
Sunday I missed the game and that's when
they cut him
he's awful in the pros awful well again
I wonder if that's just that
self-sabotage yeah no he thought he
could get away with it because he got
away within College partying the night
before Alabama then pulling off winning
but Pros are different man yeah
and it's interesting that Pros did their
homework and he went what 26 is that
what it was 22nd I think yeah
because he's such a liability yeah just
on discipline
and and now how about during the combine
he he took all those drug tests had like
30 days of drug free and then day before
combine goes in before smokes weed and
gets drunk like what are you doing dude
all you had a week to go man
well he also suddenly got to the pros he
hated it yeah he's like this isn't fun
anymore yeah there's there's that deep
deep addiction that thing that goes on
with some people who just can't stop and
don't feel alive unless they're doing
that I mean he said I was gonna spend
all the money and put a gun on my mouth
it's like what what
that's when he was you know he got cut
by Cleveland he's like all right I'm
gonna show you how to party damn I
always go back to that thing that Mike
Tyson said God has a way of getting back
at you by giving you everything you want
before you're ready it's like yeah this
young kid when the Heisman what 20 years
old 21. can't handle all the money in
the world nobody taught you how to do it
no no one teaches you that how crazy him
and his buddy came up with the kind of
the the lie that his dad came from crazy
oil money because he they had all this
money and they haven't talked since no I
know what do you think though about like
you look at him and he was 5 10 I think
five eleven barely maybe five nine like
like it's so interesting you can't judge
a book by its cover there's something
about him like he's clearly a great
athlete right fast and all that what was
his what was his 40 was he especially
fast he ran a four or five I think at
the combine maybe four six low four six
okay which is good but it's not Lamar
Jackson right like if you're gonna run
you gotta yeah Michael Vick or something
you're running four six eight okay all
right of course I ran a four six eight
right so it's not that it's so you those
numbers are not those aren't sticking
out 31 inch verts not great so he wasn't
that explosive so much broad jump nine
five is not great was able to do some
[__] even against Alabama and this is
great team hold it off College you know
Pros different animal because it really
known as a runner like there's Runners
like the Richton that the Colts drafted
runs like a I don't know 4-3 or
something like that
Lamar Jackson's like a 4-4 guy like
there's free Lamar Jackson's big isn't
he
um six two okay but definitely not five
nine five ten and has a cannon for an
arm yeah and smart you know
230 pounds that's a big fella yeah
that's a big man that's a significantly
you go to his 40th time chin
yeah John Johnny's an interesting one
but most the people knew he wasn't gonna
be great oh my God
oh my God and they're going down 2 30
and they're going Johnny they're going
Johnny you think you're a runner I'm
sorry you said you're a runner
are you joking oh my God Danny is a
great arm
reads the field well like that's what
you compete with it
he's also MVP
this guy's a freaks man
so Johnny think about him well he said
that Lamar Jackson about Johnny not the
most athletic yeah probably not the
smartest guy in the room on discipline
didn't watch game film I mean when you
competing what are we doing that I don't
know you know hard as to be a starting
quarter you know
watch his knees and he was throwing some
crate like from his knees he was
throwing farther than most people can
yeah
unbelievable
it's crazy right yes NFL don't mess
around
no it doesn't it's it's where the truth
is and Baker Mayfield similar similar to
Johnny Manziel similar size he do works
is that he's still in the NFL he's a
starting quarterback for the Tempe now
it's his third or fourteen wow and he
works his ass up as Johnny but he's he
was he a killer and he was a Heisman
Trophy yeah he's been trophy number one
pick killer but works his ass off yeah
that size there's some you know sure
NFL's tough and he's still he's doing
okay right starting quarterback he won
the starting job with the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers replacing you know Tom Brady
how big is he
I've seen him in person I'd say maybe
five nine maybe I bet they listen at
five ten five eleven he might be five
nine was it Baker Baker Mayfield you're
about to Hype because you're so much
bigger than people no I'm telling these
guys are tiny yeah tiny and that's the
knockout
six one two oh nine
you just thinking
okay that's big though sixth one's not
small for quarterback small 209
right but he's not five nine you just
said five nine I'm telling you there's
not a chance he six one really no
why do they do that why do they inflate
I mean they deal with everything huh
do how tall did he how tall did he go
um the combine six foot it says five out
of eight what is that five eighths
so the NFL coma is six foot okay you
know which is not big for a quarterback
no
yeah so he's dragged by the Browns then
went to the Panthers they went to the
Rams for a little bit nice with Tampa
Bay
hmm six foot and he worked his tail off
what a shame though because you see it
like the ends the documentary ends was
just like
he's in that dope he's in that dope crib
though he's in Phoenix
we went to rehab but he was drinking a
beer the whole time if you noticed that
yeah he never said he was sober you know
everyone's all upset about that like you
learn nothing like or you just
and he also they said when you were cut
from the NFL how do you feel it was a
relief thank God yeah and I bet pray
felt good yeah you don't want to be
there the amount of work that takes
right disaster what what does one do uh
when you have that experience is there
is there an opening in look at Ryan Leaf
When the biggest bus had a horrible drug
addiction went to prison now he goes
around speaking to colleges and other
young athletes like there's that lane
you know
because he is a Heisman that's he is
between him and Ryan Leaf he's the
Heisman Trophy winner dude big deal big
deal not a lot of Heisman Trophy winners
out there yeah
and he's learned from his mission so
he's a cautionary Tale
it's tough though too because he's still
young he only played a year and a half
college so it's like you know he still
has a lot left to do he does whatever he
wants to do yeah he can he has his whole
life him and Mike Stud are super close
and Mike's a great guest I'm sure who is
Mike uh the the white rapper Mike oh
okay I don't know that's my boy but yeah
I I don't know what if you're Johnny I'm
sure there's other business stuff you
can do and just the networking of in
being in the Heisman and Texas A M the
network of Texas A M yeah
yep
but when you see how the NCAA screwed
him over oh God such a dirty business so
annoying we give these kids an education
we're making how much money
he had to take classes online because
you're so famous you can't go to yeah
come on yeah I love oh you guys are so
I'm so glad you take care of these guys
they leave us such an education that's
what the nil deal think about Johnny
Manziel nil these days the best thing he
said is these these schools use the
football program as their front porch
right 100 and and there's no doubt and
Johnny Manziel literally was responsible
for them 350 million dollars the idea
that he went to the pros made no sense
to me stay at a m you know but he wanted
out because he saw there just using his
name and like I said for money so he's
like I need to make some money yeah man
so it'll never happen anymore you built
them a brand new stadium like the
boosters the recruiting thanks a lot
thanks a lot did you get your education
I'm sorry after a year and doing online
classes I've learned nothing yeah
nothing it's a whole it's a scam dude
yeah and there's no one yeah I mean I
it's such a scam hearing that guy talk
like that oh my God not on my watch as
long I'm the president these kids will
never be oh man thanks dude yeah thanks
meanwhile he's on a six-figure salary
it's so frustrating how about Reggie
Bush when the Heisman Trophy and they
took it from him they're taking money oh
that's right I remember that now dim the
rules and the rules back in the day but
you can dim the rules by the rules them
the rules and the rules you're taking
like a Hummer and your mom had a house
dim the rules but it's messed up
now now don't agree with the rules but
damn the rules that's how it goes
sometimes they never took jobs my buddy
said something like that my buddy said
um I can't remember what it was
we were talking about something like
this and he said that was a login like
and he said look look man
I when you drive drunk
and you get a you get arrested you're
going to jail and you should
I'm saying that and I have driven buzzed
I don't I don't approve of it I'm
embarrassed to admit it but if I'd
gotten caught
I would I would have got that damn the
rules then the rules did you tell your
friend no [__] I said right no stupid
stories I slapped his face yeah what a
waste of time
if I kill somebody I go to prison that's
how it should go there it goes
some laws
I missed them my buddy said if I drive
down and I get arrested no I I forgot
half the story because he was talking
about
he was drawing a correlation about and
he's going what the [__] why do you put
him in jail for that what are you gonna
he's like well well the the better
example would be like Jon Jones right
like in today's usada he would have
failed the test but back then under
those current rules he failed to test so
people like oh he's completely
exonerated but no back then dim the rule
yeah so you can't really play that game
back then that was
the standard it's different now it's
like Nate Diaz Nick Diaz with the weed
they've been fine but back then dim the
rules that's right
that's right
yeah send in the rules show some magic
time the rule I will bring cigarettes in
next time show you some magic cigarettes
you can only do a cigarette because
that's what you did in the bars smoke
outside and talk to the girls and what
kind of magic would you do would they
hate hiding his head yeah
oh my God this is actually a funny video
so this guy his whole family they've
been here I've seen this you've seen it
yeah this is the whole family they've
been drinking right oh this is and then
there's this like snake that's hanging
out on the screen door what part of the
country is this Alabama or maybe George
you can look it up
oh [__]
but the whole thing is not good dude
look at him though it looks like a Viper
but it's black it's a rat snake so it's
yeah still
that could have been afterwards
you're done you ate crap though at the
end I got bit
and you could see like his whole family
they walk by the snake they have no idea
and it doesn't bite them just because
it's still hanging up pretty high so
there was a rat snake that's hilarious
so you see like she's walking and you'll
see the snake on the top of your watch
you see sir right here
this guy's walking in no Pro it's still
hanging out right there oh it goes for
that guy no I think he's just kind of
falling down because it's on the screen
and then the dad dad came in it messed
him up yeah I'd be terrified
we don't want a snake biting you in the
like that's like best
day you know the kiss of death yeah the
eyelash viper yeah if it's an eyelash
why is this in our current events I
don't know I just saw this it's so brave
Wayne Brown he's so brave so the
marketing at all
Brave yeah
listen man I don't I don't get why
people have to feel like they gotta come
out all right that's the thing it's
definitely needs a little margin needs
attention when People magazine pick it
up he does the interview with people in
magazine come on just good girl star Mae
Whitman also comes out as pansexual dude
they're so pretty so great they're so
brave that's amazing the amount of balls
have you seen that the uh did you what's
this hold on we'll stay on pansexual I
don't know if I saw the old love letter
that Barack Obama oh how he fantasized
about having sex with men all day gay
well I mean I've never I've never had
that I don't know if you've you you are
I still in
yeah I'm still not convinced that you
sure haven't gotten drunk and done
something with a guy on top I just felt
a strong or something like that kissy
kissy no but B if you were driving in
this morning I go dude can I be honest
man I don't know what's going on dude
yeah but for years I've been fantasizing
about having sex with men and you go no
no that's what you say and I had to
really focus on loving women I had to
focus on if I if I text you I said dude
I've been really struggling dude I just
all I can think about is having sex with
Bros and it's it's a struggle for me to
to keep it together with my wife
two things you text back I'd say hey if
we're driving together I go I'm straight
now careful now I'm straight now yeah
appreciate you you're confiding me
appreciate it see you know I'm afraid
but I'd say gay yeah 100 you gay yeah
it's fine but you know the conspiracy
guys like uh like Sam Tripoli and Eddie
Bravo they've been talking about this
forever they've been saying that that uh
Barack is gay they're always like
Michelle's a beard well yeah Michelle's
Michelle might be a beard I've heard
this
who knows what to believe these days
well he did write that no that that's so
so that's legitimate it's a legit the
letter is legit and those are facts
those were already demographer
rid that portion because the woman who
gave it to him to the guy said this
paragraph is about homosexuality and I'm
redacting it so she didn't want it to be
in the thing the woman he dated but then
it became a matter of public record they
weren't allowed to take pictures of it
because it was private property but then
it became now it's a matter of fact let
me ask you this does it matter no I
don't care do you care I don't care I
just think it's significant
conspiracy theories tell me that so
let's say salmonella you're right
I do think it's a little interesting but
who but my whole thing yeah it's
interesting to talk about my whole thing
I don't care no I don't either but but I
don't get why people care right but I I
I'm so strange bro I don't care no no I
I'm so strange I don't care hey take it
easy I get a I get I get worried when
you kid too much no I just think it's
interesting that this thing is hot the
president of the United States is hot
bro I don't manage nice mouth I don't I
don't though and play some ball to him
what and play some balls shirt off but I
I just think it's interesting
that uh his Chef died for no reason
that he's a gay killer and that's what I
think
I I think it's fascinating how obsessed
people are with this I saw it everywhere
and I was like all right even if it was
like him you know confessing like I've
had sex like 300 men I'd be like damn
that's crazy what you got I just think
no I just think it's interesting that
that I think about it I don't see color
dude him deciding I'm gonna marry
somebody even though I like men back
then a lot of guys had to Elton John had
a wife yeah back then it was different
he won't be you think he'd be president
if he came out that he was gay yeah you
think he's you think he's um embarrassed
by it right now
or no
at his level congrats you know my best
friend's like oh I bet such a relief man
you probably feel like bigger you
probably feel like Johnny Manziel we got
fired from the NFL just such a relief he
can
suck [__] now
right
listen let's think of this band stop
cussing is that cussing yeah or is that
OA or those facts give him the rules
okay can you not skip the rules metaphor
can you say
can you say he likes a Persian cucumber
salad oh no I don't know he's like a
Persian cucumber no he's into bratwurst
there you go yeah like a little
bratwurst he eats a lot of bratwurst
there you go
yeah it's not fun is it
well it's nothing like the [__] maybe oh
it's fun you know what I mean they're
taking all our fun away I know dude it's
because
um I just don't I don't
I just don't care
I think it's interesting
I know exactly why is it interesting no
I know what you mean I I guess what I'm
saying is that I'm surprised so in a way
that's how non-homophobic I am I'm just
I saw him like no no no I'm not that's
not actually what I'm I I just think to
myself what else don't we people what
else do not even that there are people
the aliens are going to make a so there
are people you and I were talking about
this a certain politician people build a
house and they have to hold up they they
have to uh oh you're talking about my
least favorite competition yeah they
have to hold up they have to hold an
image in their head right they have to
pretend to be somebody they're not that
was must be exhausting because in a way
you're lying about a fundamental part of
your nature right and that's got to be
very tough and I hope the juice is worth
the squeeze and so you and I know
somebody who who's a very famous
politician know of maybe and I think you
think he's that way I think he's a
terrible human being I think full of
[__] oh the guy we're talking about oh I
agree with you I think he's a terrible
person I don't think he's a facade I
think he's actually a terrible oh no I'm
saying he's he's uh no I don't think
he's fake built his in his career his
his thing on a lie so he's lying and he
made but he knows I know that yeah I I
I'm not a fan at all I'm what I'm saying
is that that this is a little different
than Obama right yeah this other guy is
a complete frog different and Obama's
that you know yeah right and I think
when you're that much of a fraud
I don't care what you go to you will
always hide from truth tellers you'll
hide from people I think for Barack more
I don't I probably don't care too much
at this point but when he was running
he's probably super stressed out about
it because you're not gonna win yeah
especially back then was that 2008 yeah
you're not winning president being yeah
I don't think a gay president could win
now I agree with you you're out of your
mind you think guy's gonna come out just
like boot Pete booty Gage a chance put
it again I can't say his name so that's
a problem yeah
no he's not winning not a chance he
can't even get our bus system in order
let alone run a country yeah it's but
but with Obama I think he was like man
we can't have this get out that I like
dudes because I'm not gonna be able to
run for president
think about he doesn't like he wouldn't
smoke weed or drink because he wanted to
be president let alone sucking well
can I say that like that I think that's
how my God I think that's I think I like
that more thank you actually
um is he uh
yeah I bet that boy is wild berry
's throat game Daddy
bear his throat game let me ask you this
you think Barry acted out some of them
fantasies what here's all the resources
to make that happen
he catches nuts
and nuts
is there a code for that you chipmunk
no he's just nuts
scrolling up
swamp boom squirrel hey come on man come
on come on please look inside yeah
he swung hey come on dude look at the
side bro Barry don't get his flag bro
the old berry Big Gulp because we called
the money man
big gold Berry never heard that all
right let's let's move on man hurry up
chin move on Big Gulp Obama you never
heard that
Hillary Clinton
uh have you heard of this uh female is
she's a WNBA player Liz cambodage fight
with Nigerian players emerges after oh I
saw this she like soccer she's a girl
too like yeah she's gigantic
Liz said something racist regarding the
Nigerian national team they were
training with and then this is the
reaction from the team
Australian Nigerian game where the NBA
star Liz Camp Kombat was seen elbowing
slapping opponents in the face in the
same incident cameras allegedly called
upon's monkeys Cambridge was swung at uh
so the question question from the white
guy straight male white guy over here um
hard on straight there did is it a white
girl no so that's another
African-American it's an
African-American called Africans
that's where it gets dicey we hit the
video so she's the biggest girl in this
video
see she she plays right here see how big
she is look at her they're getting
physical and now the fans
the elbows are right in the face right
there boom
now as you can tell business is a boom
and look how many people in the stands
oh she's way too big to fight oh oh she
gets dealt with yeah she does get dealt
with
now white girls in the middle like I do
not want these problems out here but
she's a large woman though sure Watch
What Happens this large woman
so there's another thing and she's a
light-skinned black woman so here she
goes again Watch so I'm gonna look up
her actual ethnicity I think she's half
for sure but
she's here she slaps her in the face
right first of all she's seven seven
slot for the face but check this out so
this girl gets revenge on her watch that
girl's like hell no watch what she does
good punch too solid punch oh hold on
boom Oh that was a punch we need to sign
up for the UFC oh that was good damn
these guys she rocked that big gal whoa
so those of you watching there's nobody
in the stands and there's
um and her teammates didn't defend her
by the way that looks like a gym that
looks like a pickup game in a gym that
looks like the practice take my
seven-year-old too literally nobody was
watching that game
oh boy
how big is Liz is that that are right
there
that's her Sheila has to be mixed right
uh yeah chin uh yes there's five
thousand Alex what gave that away the
black lives matter Nigerian and
Australia Obama I missed the nurture
large Lady Obama
um
hey I focus on Liz get can you not
man you gotta get that look off your
face because you got that Mischief going
on bro and I'm trying to keep things
clean hashtag big old Berry man I'm
trying to keep things clean chin help me
how tall is she I don't want to title
that episode
pretty it's kind of pretty yeah she's a
pretty girl no yeah she's definitely she
looks pretty and a lot of Obama's going
uh
look at her
don't come light in the ass now look at
her at the ESPYs though you got to bring
some heat that's a bad pig but go to the
S3 ones this one yeah very pretty what a
what a stunning woman my Lord
now now she's good here you go
Brennan you could step up to that I
don't know even I'm a little too light
in the ass but you might step up to it
yeah I'll do my best shot man yeah like
a carnival game I'll take my best she's
not she is tremendous bro those jerseys
do her no just a beautiful woman those
boxes if I try to do it it would look
like like the way uh somebody throws a
baton in the air she would if you were
if you were walking on the street
shooting at you like you're homeless
meaning she wouldn't even look it she'd
Pat my head and give me a lunch pail and
send me to school that's what she would
do okay
she's cool she doesn't seem cool but
she's attractive she's cool dude she
plays for Keeps he plays for Keeps she's
playing on American I mean I'm in
prisoner she's not taking any like now
date her but there are men out there
that are into a big woman oh big time
dude yeah that's a whole fetish you got
to be packing real heat you just just
added just to be polite you gotta pack
oh don't disrespect her man you know
what I mean you got to be packing heavy
oh look at her's Buzz Lightyear
hmm
I'm so impressed I I had all these ideas
there's a snake in my boot now you feel
me girl now
um dude I'll be her Woody yeah there
there are there are there are men in the
NBA that'd be all over it though I don't
know I don't know if the NBA gets like
that's not real no it's not
the shoe clearly hasn't only fans oh
she's a lesbian is she
I think so she has a tattoo on her neck
what man I've seen way too much first
48. all right dude it's a sheretail sign
no I don't know about that bro big old
baby okay
get me out of here man we got to get him
off the the Obama thing
oh she's all cuddled up with Drake
yeah but no
she had health concerns around covid-19
okay well we gotta change that that's
not that's a small talk you give me 30
minutes with her I'll get her [__]
taking the mask off mask off
you big old thick kid man you know I'm
two letting the pants for her though I
think she's gorgeous four inches shorter
gorgeous this is crazy four inches
that's me you
that'd be cool what'd she wear I wonder
I weigh more than her you think so I'm
dance man you're dancing she's probably
2 30 6 8 2 3 16.
so it was 235 yeah see even at 6 8 235
216 all dimed up like that yeah
oh dude she's she's British uh-huh oh
wow oh Australian Australia and she
plays the Australian team boy this is
confusing
British but plays for the Australian
national team but plays with LA spark
and the team that she had a controversy
with she says that she's working it out
with them to join that team the Nigerian
team so there's a lot of stuff going on
here okay damn she scored 53 points in
the game
well splashed it you ever heard of
Splash Brothers
Splash tits
am I too much for YouTube I like it
thanks man I like that you're feeling a
little mischievous because like vintage
tea fat K big old Berry
that's a shirt that somebody needs to
make
um we should probably make it big golf
buried
people buy it someone's already making
it right now
they go Barry man she's cool thanks for
that Chad that's a real gift today dude
I'd rather see her than your magic you
haven't seen the magic yet one day true
but we gotta bring in some Marlboro Reds
we can even buy those
do they sell my gas stations we could
buy them no problem right now I'm liking
our chairs
we feel better here
I like that you're still uh you're still
keeping in these chairs but why I don't
know
you know it's just your politics and
stuff
how do you feel that your co-host now
before we have the tides turn it's not
my Crowder now Jones and you uh Alex is
on the platform yeah it's going to be in
teammate
it's gonna be interesting you know with
those three big gold Barry right
um
yeah you're a dude you did go very much
hey don't use that word either man we're
gonna get flagged bro there's so much I
can't even mentioned you can't even
mention AJ's name where that's going to
flag us too AJ
yeah oh you can't even say his name
bleep his name out
you're gonna have to say now though
that's your teammate hey bro
he thinks you're a CIA plant you know
that right I know he was calling me that
he kept doing it actually well we were
at Crowder and I was working on it good
that's a CIA Commando training yeah
he's like dead set on it though
and I co-signed that are we done well I
mean uh hey lol San Antonio I'm going to
see you August 24 25 26. great club man
oh it's going to be great stay in a
hotel Emma I am staying at hotel Emma uh
great Hotel shout out to Hotel I'm
actually reached out to me Wise Guys uh
September one and two can't wait for
that either great you and I are doing
the fight companion September 9 the
September 8th we're in Covina one night
only two shows Covina Laugh Factory me
and Brian together for the first time in
years it's me and big Galt Brian we're
in Covina September 8th two shows almost
sold out big old Brian and then
September 9th we're doing the fight
companion with Mr Joseph Rogan Sam
tripley and myself and then uh end of
September September 21st through the
23rd I'm in Spokane Washington and then
we're in skank Fest in Las Vegas
September 29th through October 1st
Niagara Falls New York November 4th
through the 5th I have to reschedule
Omaha and
um Kansas City That was supposed to be
Wednesday Thursday a because I have to
stay here to shoot podcasts and I can't
give up on the show I can't we gotta
make this a priority man buddy now my
question big golf Barry would you do the
same I wouldn't know you wouldn't you
piece
yeah I'd be here you're mad at me you're
mad at me at my Columbia so just so you
guys know Brennan I'm in Colombia and we
we try to do those two makeup shows in
in Austin never really works when you
stack them well here's the other thing
Brian goes hey I'm not here next week we
gotta do two shows in Austin this was on
Friday yeah so we had I'm like wait
you're gone all next week after our huge
mazlo episode okay yeah so let's figure
it out I'm getting texts from running on
dude man you know kind of like shitty
you're gone and he's complaining because
I know he's frustrated and he's got to
send some [__] my way in Colombia and I
would just be like dude can I call you
back I'm sipping coffee right now the
the studio is whatever I can handle that
the the biggest thing was the the the
siding with our new Advertiser got some
good stuff going on yeah we do we have a
lot of good stuff I'm liking this new
studio buddy it's nice man
feels good he's been our guy since day
one he got famous on us but he's made
time for the little guys yeah man that's
good Wednesday we had two big guests
they'll be sitting on that couch we'll
talk about big gold Berry with them yeah
I'm excited about that too you like that
big gold Brian
right what's your name right dude
let's go get a Big Gulp dude
feeling frisky yeah
yeah hey remember you didn't know what
the UFC was this weekend
hey can you tell us our the story again
about your friend driving drunk
all right kids love you love you guys
all Barry we don't need to wear those
though right I have to man why who gave
those to you p-rod take them off girl
that's enough leave my shoes
how much are these no I don't know a lot
Maybe
how much are they
I can't I just can't I can't dude
you can't wear these it makes me mad
you're 40. dude what I know I mean a kid
would go into a seizure looking at that
you're you would all right come on hey
you know what that's not bad stop stop
playing around I don't think I got
strong feet
I don't see color are they multicolored
there's you wouldn't even colorblind
that's such a disaster I only see truth
where where are the shoes you were
joking around don't give me a big no
get them off
that's so frustrating man ah were you
filming that oh [__]